we dedicate tonight's show
to a man whose spirit touched so many he
is a true hero
last night's vmas honored chadwick who
won an mtv movie
and tv award in 2018 for black panther
the actor was also honored in the in
memoriam segment
but that sparked some outrage fans lit
up twitter demanding the late kobe
bryant also be honored
one wrote quote you added naya and
chadwick
you weren't sticking to just music
others were upset thinking the night
stars got to be exempt from new york's
14-day quarantine
but et's learned many weren't actually
even in new york
[Music]
the weekend's rooftop pyrotechnics
performance was pre-taped
miley's was too but she shot hers in los
angeles
giving us major wrecking ball vibes to
celebrate
that song's seventh anniversary
lady gaga had a pandemic style stripper
pole entrance
she played a brain piano and swept the
awards
wearing nine different mass and matching
outfits
all that including her performance with
ariana was done from la
and it left mother monster exhausted
mtv stuck fans in cars and streamed them
into the virtual set
host kiki palmer was also sometimes
green screened in like the presenters so
they'd all look like they were in the
same place
including on the virtual white carpet a
few winners
simply stayed home megan the stallion
thank you for everything i hope i get to
see you soon you won
the vma dude that is yours
pre-show interviews were recorded in
advance and et has learned all talent
and crew had to test negative before
hitting the stage
everyone was also quarantined when not
working whoever i do come into contact
with
just know we've all taken 30 tests
you